menos preciosa y menos público en este
segundo día de los 49 que debe durar
este proceso por los atentados de enero
del año 2015 en parís - público pero más
policía alrededor de este edificio del
palacio de justicia aquí en la puerta de
clichy donde se han establecido
diferentes entradas ya sea para la
prensa para los abogados de la parte
civil y para el público eso sobre todo
después de la publicación nuevamente por
saliendo de las caricaturas de mahoma y
este segundo día de juicio estado
dedicado a conocer la personalidad de
los 11 acusados que están presentes en
este juicio pero al comienzo ha habido
muchos problemas de audio recordemos que
este juicio se realiza en una sala pero
es repetido en otras cinco por lo tanto
es muy importante que se escuche bien en
esos lugares donde hay testigos donde
hay parte civil y donde también está la
prensa tras perder muchos minutos en eso
escuchamos el testimonio de abdel aziz a
bach él está acusado de pertenecer al
grupo que consiguió armas tanto
paramédico y bali y los hermanos que
allí está acusado también de haber
tenido
con uno de ellos él se dice inocente
dice que es una persona que creció en un
hogar musulmán que está es una región de
paz no de matar personas y dice saber el
dolor que está pasando a las familiares
de las víctimas los sobrevivientes y
compartirlo